do you believe in like Supernatural
stuff Have You Ever Seen ghosts or stuff
like I haven't and I want to oh come
over to my
house um yes I know they show themselves
to me that thank God they haven't
actually shown themselves cuz I don't
know if I wouldn't be here right now I
would want to see it you think that you
I 100% think it would be cool okay well
I have I've had some things happen I've
lost both my parents and I've had some
things happen like a lot of things
happened especially after my mom passed
away um were very strange uh things
happen like lights going on where they
weren't even plugged in really weird
things yeah so um I have no doubt I
believe in that and then my house that I
live in now was built in like 1882 and
moved by like trolley in
1912 and I hear footsteps a lot everyone
in my family has heard the footsteps
yeah and Smokey Robinson actually used
to own my home and I was at an Oscar
party this past Oscars and he said oh
have you heard the footsteps yet I did
not need to hear that I was like I
wanted to believe that I was imagin it
but the funny thing is like it feels
safe though it's like a good experence
yeah I don't feel insafe around it yeah
but we've seen the movies we don't know
what's G to happen those are movies
though I really want to see one Kyle
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home h